mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
this is a fun problem for valentine's
day or any day of the year
start with the square whose side lengths
are equal to one
on two adjacent sides construct
semi-circles
to form a heart shape the final step of
the construction
is to circumscribe a circle around the
heart
the question is what is the radius of
the large circle
i thank steven from belgium for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
recall if two circles are tangent their
centers and the tangent point are
collinear
suppose we have circles a and b that are
tangent at point t
construct the tangent line through the
point t
by construction a t will be
perpendicular to the tangent line
and bt will also be perpendicular to the
tangent line
therefore atb is a straight line
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent
circles now let's solve the problem
first construct the center of the large
circle and the center of the semicircle
construct a line segment between the two
centers and the tangent point
suppose a large circle has a radius
equal to r
the semicircle has a radius that's one
half the side length of the square
so it will be equal to 0.5
therefore the distance between the two
centers is equal to
r minus 0.5 we will also have
another radius of the semicircle and its
length will be equal to 0.5
construct a cord of the circle exactly
through the middle of this diagram
notice it will be a diameter of the
large circle
and it will go through two corners of
the square
since the square has a side length equal
to 1 the diagonal of the square
will be equal to the square root of 2.
next notice this is a radius of the
large circle
therefore this distance will be equal to
the square root of 2 minus r
we also know that one of the angles in
this triangle will be equal to half of
90 degrees
or 45 degrees we can thus focus on this
triangle
and its lengths we've reduced this
problem to one of trigonometry
from here we'll be able to solve for r
using alkashy's law of cosines
it's a familiar formula we can simply
apply this formula to the side lengths
and the angle
we will then simplify this equation to
solve for r
to do that we'll expand each binomial
and simplify
each side of the equation then
we will simplify this equation by
canceling like terms
we now simplify each side of the
equation and we get a linear
equation in r we can group the r terms
together
and then solve for r to make things a
little bit cleaner
we can rationalize this fraction we'll
multiply the numerator and the
denominator
by the conjugate of the denominator
once we simplify we get that r is equal
to 3 times the square root of 2
plus 2 all over 7 and that's
approximately equal
to 0.892 and that's
our answer thanks for making us one of
the best communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems
one video at a time
you